[Music]
you never have to worry about many of
life's unfortunate situations ruining
your mood ever again we're here to teach
you the ways you can easily avoid a few
of these common problems to make your
life easier if you're new to our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up because
today we're sharing 10 ways to avoid
unfortunate situations that we've all
been in number 10 avoid a wardrobe
malfunction walking around with your
zipper down is one of the most
embarrassing situations ever but
thankfully you no longer have to worry
about inadvertently flashing your goods
during your next wardrobe malfunction to
keep your flag close all you have to do
is attach a key ring to the pull of the
zipper then loop the key ring around the
button to keep your zipper where it
belongs all day long number 9
stop your charger from breaking one of
the most annoying things about our cell
phones is that their Chargers never seem
to last very long after a few months the
cords begin to bend and fray and before
you know it you have to shell out some
cash to buy a brand new one but using
the coil that's found inside retractable
pens is an easy way to prevent your
Chargers untimely death just remove the
foil from your pen and wrap it around
the upper part of the cord where it
connects to the plug the coils will hold
your cord in place and prevent it from
getting damaged number eight never get
bored of studying if you have problems
staying focused when you're studying for
a big exam since next trip will help
keep you awake and alert just grab some
gummi bears and place them on various
areas of your textbook of your reading
when you reach the spot where a gummy
bear is you can reward yourself by
eating it this will only keep you
focused on reading the material but
it'll also keep you motivated to reach
the next gummy bear number 7 hands-free
iPhone on a plane the next time you're
on an airplane you don't have to worry
about holding your phone in your hands
while you watch your favorite shows and
movies this answering method will ensure
you don't accidentally drop and break
your phone during your plane ride or
accidentally spill your soda on top of
it just place your device inside a
ziploc bag and it catch it did the tray
latch that's in front of you
the hole in the side of the bag so that
you can plug in your earphones and you
can enjoy some hands-free entertainment
for hours
number six never lose your electronics
how many times a month do you lose your
cell phone in your TV's remote controls
if your answer is a billion don't worry
you're not alone this simple solution is
the answer to all of our wishes
just add some velcro to your coffee
table or desk and add another piece to
the back of your remote control and cell
phone when you're done using your
electronics you can attach them to the
velcro so you'll never have to worry
about losing them again number five
goodbye lipstick stains lipstick looks
beautiful on your lips but it looks
pretty horrible when it rubs off on your
crush's clothing to make sure your
lipstick stays put all day long
apply your favorite colors then take a
piece of tissue and separate it into
individual layers take the tiniest layer
and place it against your mouth then
dust a bit of translucent powder on top
of the tissue and it will stop your
lipstick from transferring don't believe
us give it a try yourself
number four never hammer your fingers
again
the next time you need to hammer a nail
don't run the risk of accidentally
hammering your finger too instead use a
clothespin to grip the nail you can not
hold the end of the pin that's farthest
away from where you'll be hammering this
way you don't have to worry about
accidentally bashing your finger number
three keep valuables safe at the beach
bringing a purse or backpack to the
beach isn't always a good idea if you
want to make sure your valuables are
kept safe you need to find an
alternative way to keep them hidden and
away from these the solution is to empty
out a plastic sunscreen bottle and it's
the perfect hitting compartment for you
to secretly conceal your keys money and
any other valuable items you have number
two waterproof your phone whether you're
spending the day at the pool or going on
a water ride at an amusement park
waterproofing your cell phone is a mud
there are a bunch of accessories on the
market that will protect your device but
we have an even better solution a condom
that's right just place your phone
inside a condom and tie the end into a
knot even with the condom
on you're still able to use the
touchscreen on your device and the
condom will provide a tight seal around
your phone to protect it from even the
tiniest droplet of water number one ride
an elevator without stopping if you're
in a hurry and you don't have time to
wait for an elevator to stop on every
floor this church will save the day all
you have to do is press the close button
until the doors shut keep your finger on
the button while pressing the floor
number that you're going to this will
keep the elevator from stopping and
you'll be able to arrive at your
destination without any delays will you
be giving any of these solutions to
unfortunate situations a shot let us
know which one you'll be trying in the
comment section below and don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up
[Music]
you
[Music]